constitutional and important at the
final day of katanji brown jackson's
confirmation hearings even opponents of
her nomination to the supreme court were
agreed on one thing i think you should
make no mistake that i agree she is
highly qualified judges are supposed to
be
over four days republicans attempted to
portray jackson as soft on crime as a
former public defender allow her to
finish please and soft on terrorism due
to her work for detainees at guantanamo
bay even though the right to legal
counsel is constitutionally protected
the constitution does not get suspended
in times of emergency there was a
particular focus on cases involving
child pornography but her sentencing
record is in keeping with the majority
of other judges in the
u.s you gave him three months my
question is do you regret it or not
senator
what
i regret
is that in a hearing
about
my qualifications to
be
a justice on the supreme court we've
spent a lot of time
focusing
on this
small subset of my sentences democrats
on the committee chose to focus on the
history being made with judge jackson's
nomination you're here
and i know what it's taken for you to
sit in that seat
i see my ancestors and yours
for some court watchers this was a
confirmation hearing filled with
conflicting emotions from anger to pride
her having to sit there and be
demeaned and belittled when this woman
really has more intellect more
qualifications to really be quite honest
than the present nine justices that are
on the bench jackson pledged to quote
stay in her lane that is only interpret
law from the bench and not create new
law through her judgments and it was
clear she was well aware of the
symbolism of her nomination i do
consider myself having been born in 1970
to be
the first generation
to benefit from the civil rights
movement from the legacy of
all of the work
of so many people that went into
changing the laws in this country so
that people like me
could have an opportunity to be sitting
here before you today the senate
judiciary committee will vote on
jackson's nomination on april the 4th if
then confirmed by the full senate she
will make history as the first
african-american woman associate justice
but she won't alter the ideological
balance off the supreme court
shia britancy al jazeera washington